what's driving you crazy at 6 25 on your
Wednesday morning got a heads up on a
weather-related change in plans to those
Lane restrictions on Desert Inn Between
Valley View and Paradise now overnight
and early morning drivers know all too
well about the flashing lights and the
cones sending you left one night right
the next or even both
the Nevada Department of
transportation's Justin Hopkins says
workers on that project need warmer
temperatures to put down what's called a
polymer concrete overlay this week
they've taken away one of the westbound
Lanes starting at that tunnel under Las
Vegas Boulevard work hours 7 A.M to 4
P.M but Hopkins says the lane closures
will stay in effect at night so the
concrete polymer can settle
Crews also working to replace Bridge
joints doing other updates to that super
arterial and they're not done yet so you
need to be ready for more Lane
restrictions in the weeks to come buckle
up drive carefully please put down that
phone join the driving you crazy
conversation we are traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com